this guy's called alexander price hello
and he's got three rent to service
accommodation apartments in berkshire
how's it going
it's going really well three three units
so far and uh yeah
looking to build on that soon and you
know what you he got his first property
just after going on the
rental revolution yeah absolutely and
and and uh he did the script got the
property but this was just before the
pandemics he was like oh my goodness
and he managed to make it break even
just after he got it but then june how
much do you make of that one
apartment in june just under a thousand
pound profit just to do a thousand man
this is the thing with rent to service
accommodation you don't need
10 20 of them to become financially free
you just need two or three you've got
three now
he's got three now that's it three
properties can make the world a
difference you know full-time in
property
full-time in property this is it don't
think you need 10 20 30 houses to change
your life you just need two or three
would you agree
100 boom i'm just so glad to share
seriously just like you know from
everything i've learned and experience
i'm so glad to be able to you know to
share it with people
yeah i just think it's it's a blessing
to be able to say you know
i've made mistakes you know you get some
education get yourself around the right
people and
make it happen so what happened is i had
a family food business
in july 20 june 2018 we shut that down
my dad needed a hip operation leave the
holiday and while i was working every
hour at god sends and it was just
it was just intense we all needed a
holiday we've been doing it for like
five years
working seven days a week for about five
years um
joined the liquid nitrogen ice cream
company in july 18
worked there for a year i had a great
time but
i've gone from running my own business
to helping this a friend of mine who had
met through the food company run his
business
events company doing weddings and
corporate events etc
and coming to the august september time
september was really rough in the day
job lots of stuff
shitty stuff happened basically and i
was just like i know i want to do this
property thing
and i basically handed my notice in at
the end of september and i left at the
end of october
wow and i was just like right i'm just
gonna go full time this property thing
make it happen
um and that's why so i literally left on
the wednesday the 30th
was my last day in the day job thursday
31st of october
i had a date with my girlfriend saying
right listen ending
chapter here half terms while she's a
teacher so like let's have a really
awesome day together
from tomorrow onwards it's going to be
it's not going to be tough but i'm going
to be pretty damn focused on this
property thing i really want to make
this happen
it's literally that friday first of
november that's why i'm really excited
to go on the crash course a lot wicked
my first day full-time property
on a property course with this dude
samuel leeds who knows what's going to
happen
let's just get involved and you know
yeah be part of it and be crazy
and yeah and i just at the end of that
first day in the academy sorry
in the crash course i was like i'm full
time
a lot of these people who are signing up
to the academy they're not full-time
there's going to be a part-time thing
for them but they're going to have to
squeeze around their life i've got the
benefit i can
just go at this 110 just go for it yeah
and will i
in 12 months time when i'd be like oh
i've saved up enough money samuel can i
join the academy or will i just be like
sorry i should have just just
just gone the academy has pitched very
much middle of the road in terms of
price
compared to if anything lower yeah it is
people don't realize that but it is
yeah um my dad like you know simon
zucchi's got his 20k yeah
trying to get like but he's not in that
circle
so you just can't see that i was like
it's access to that networking
environment
um but no but when i when you first
spoke to me i was like okay well you'll
be great have a chat
uh i thought i'll get my website ready
you know get ready for this big exposure
on youtube but actually
throw all of that away i just wanted to
come say thank you oh thanks man well
so i want to buy a little something um
that's very kind um
and genuinely because as i came out of
my last day job
um i thought right you know i've had
this vision i've been taught i've been
telling other people about positive
thinking telling other people to do a
vision board i've been telling other
people to meditate
but i'm still not really my results just
aren't really showing
i feel great and i value so much and i
feel rich in every way but this damn
this money thing just wasn't coming
together until
you know this last year where i did my
100 days of happiness challenge which by
the time we met though
because you you've done some different
training you did kevin green you've done
a touchdown with a bit of touchdown
you've done a little bit of and some of
it was paid for
yes training and and and when we met
um you'd literally just quit your job
yeah and you were in a really good place
physically emotionally spiritually
mentally
but just not financially yes like and
you were like look
you know i've done all this training and
i've done a lot of personal development
type stuff
and my mindset's good and i'm positive
and i've watched dr
john d martini and this person and that
and i've read the secret
and i'm ready and i want to buy a boat
and sail around the world
and i've had all this 10 years of
grafting and crap where
i've worked hard but i've just never
quite done it financially
and that was that was where where we
first met it's weird because when i was
at the academy
so i went to the crash course and i
joined the academy
i only just wanted for me just one of
those moments i was just like i've done
business for like 12 years now
taking us since closing the family food
business down
over a year of family meetings every
single week to get on top of our
finances
yeah with the family food business it
was hand to mouth you know we barely had
enough money to pay the bills we ended
up going into more debt through the
business
yeah um and i was just like we can't you
know my dad would be like oh we're
firefighting
you know we can still pay the bills i
was like yeah but we're just we've
barely got ahead of other water here
this isn't right you know there's more
to life
yeah and we had a meeting every single
wednesday for like a year
and that's what it took to get our
family finances on track luckily mum and
dad's pensions kicked dad's pension
kicked in the mums came in
just a bit afterwards they had some lump
sum payments as well um
so i'd spent the 12 years since 2008
just trying to support my family just
trying to bring the
dad had the stream of the family food
business called the spicy chef
um i wanted to help him live that dream
and i thought it could help build up our
finances but just just never
expanded contracted expanded contracted
it never really took off
the way i could never systemize it yeah
that was the big thing
you know i tried to look at outsourcing
stuff and dad was so passionate about
making the food himself that i just
i could see that him letting go of that
it wasn't necessarily gonna work at the
time
um and so when it came to september
october we'd got the family finances
back on track
um and i said you know i'm really
serious about this property thing you
know me
i'm very fortunate i'm very close to my
family my sister came back from uni as
well in 2018 when we shut the food
business down so she helped support the
family
with her income and she got a job
locally um i said you know i'm serious
about this
will you please support me for the first
you know from
november to february march and i think
three four months i should be able to
get a deal together
and then you know if i need to get a
part-time job i will but let me just go
hammer and tongs at it for these first
few months
and uh and they were like you know yeah
we'll support you uh mom and dad had a
bit of money so they said like i said my
expenses are like
three four hundred pounds a month that's
all i need to live uh i had a chat with
my girlfriend because
unless she was paying for the one
bedroom flat by herself and she had
signed
she'd signed up to contact myself with
the deals that you know i would
eventually contribute towards it
as that's another thing we're hopefully
gonna move to our two bed in the next
few months which would be which would be
great and have an office there etcetera
but i had that discussion with them and
i said uh and
i sort of remember sort of at dfe uh the
question and answer time
um this fella stood up and said oh
should i quit my job and then sort of
two weeks later he started some youtube
channel trying to hack away you and i
was like
oh just i just thought dude you know
you haven't committed if you'd really
committed you'd have said
i've made a commitment i'm not going
back on it yeah and
you know i've had a discussion my girl
from many times because she's in a
comfortable place but unhappy with her
job
and i've always been a situation of my
life is actually fantastic
you know i've always had food on the
table roof over my head i've still got
some you know some clothes to wear i
never go close shopping people always
buy me clothes which is great thank you
um but you know um if i need to
sacrifice all of that live in a
cardboard box i genuinely would
you know as long as my family's well you
know i don't care if that's what if i
just need to shed it all and just crack
on and make something happen
there are people who've come into this
country with less yeah and made it
happen through sometimes watching your
videos or sometimes through reading
books or watching other stuff etcetera
so i just knew that it was you know more
was possible
and for me because i came into business
in the recession in 2008
i didn't realize we'd come out of
recession yeah and i've only realized
this literally in the last year
is that just when we got back into
another one well yeah quite like
unemployment was the lowest it's ever
been wasn't it like november last year
december last year
and i was like crumb so the economy's
been doing really well but for the last
10 years i feel like i've been in this
recession because it was just such a
struggle to make ends meet with the food
business
we had some great months but you know we
could the most holiday we ever took was
like three days in august to go and see
my auntie on the south coast
you know you know what that's it's like
you make your own economy so you
probably were in a recession yeah 100
yeah your world was a recession my world
was an expansion
very true so it's about and i think
that's a really important
lesson sometimes you can think what's
the economy doing it's actually
what's my economy going to do so talk to
me about what happened how you found the
deals and what happened i mean first
we did some role play at the deal
finding extravaganza which went well
yes i think it went well one of them
went badly i can't remember but
talk me through about some of the
training because i know that directly
resulted in the deals yes
so talk to me about that so my first
ever time at one of your
your events as i heard about this guy
samuel something's great something's not
so great
i know it's really high energy uh let's
just go and see what it's about you've
heard a lot of controversy because at
this time
it was crazy like the media and what was
happening
and and for me i just always knew that
you said about creating your own economy
i create my i believe we create our own
experience and i was like
whatever stuff's going on i'm not here
to validate it that's not my position
my position here is to you know give as
much positive energy as i can and try
and build this business i'm trying to
build
if i'm surrounded by people who are all
heading in the same direction i just
knew being in that environment was going
to be so key
um to just helping me take to the next
level and although we've been locked
down
you know the i've still managed to keep
in contact with a lot of the academy
members which has been fantastic it's
great seeing darren and ella sitting on
the on the seats here
uh on their video a few weeks ago i got
to know them on that because they were
there on that crash course as well
yeah we had crash course i think a week
or so later i had
like the introduction three days in
infinite returns in london
yeah and that was great and i was just
like great to network with everyone the
networking was fantastic in those events
and a few weeks later over in birmingham
for the deal for extravaganza
i remember you would come on stage i
think for the morning and
maybe day two there's like a room of 500
people and it's you know
really high energy which is what i love
about the events i think that really
helps give you momentum forward after
those weekends it's
a bit of a downer on the monday but
you're like no i've i felt that great
and it's
i had that momentum let's just carry
that through to the week and it was a
deal fun extravaganza where
you came in to talk about lease option
agreements and you said right we're
gonna do some role play who wants to
volunteer
and i think i was the only person in the
room that put their hand up
so i jumped up on stage i'm sort of
getting my phone out instead of
imagining and you're walking around the
room asking your questions as a landlord
and i was there as someone who had sent
you a landlord letter saying
oh yeah you've received my list yes can
you remind me of your address please et
cetera and doing all these pro
all these things and it's really funny
because darren as in darren and ella who
are here
he was like i was looking at samuel and
he was trying to ask you these questions
and you kept
answering and he kept looking down
thinking crumbs how do i challenge this
guy
i managed to kind of get through that
role play okay but then we had the
uh rent to end revolution in january the
crowd cheered as well
you absolutely nailed it because and
that's the thing
what i'll do when i'm teaching is i'll
i'll say what you need to do
then i'll do it and i'll pick up the
phone and call agents and stuff and i'm
like
right now it's your turn i'll get
someone up on stage and then
everyone roll plays and put gets himself
in groups or partners but when you came
up you
you did kill that like word for word and
i was just like
can't really particularly actually be
fair go get some deals there
but then what happened at the rental rep
revolution when we do when we did the
same
but for service accommodation and demand
exactly so so
uh sort of january i was probably sort
of a bit full of myself i need to be
taking down a peg or two so
i sort of said who's going to volunteer
and i'm like yeah go on it's just going
to be me and oh alex yeah off yeah
coming
it was all about just bringing up the
state agent going yep hi i'm interested
in this property
check has they got the bathrooms the
bedrooms et cetera cool it's going to be
for corporate
i'd like to view it tomorrow and i just
couldn't quite get that process right
it comes easily enough now and i got it
wrong like three or four times and
everyone's shouting at me like
no you got this bit wrong but when 200
people are trying to shout at you it's a
bit harder
exactly what you're meant to do or what
you're doing wrong and then you were
there kind of like you're almost there
alex okay
he's trying he's tried yeah um but
thankfully
you went through that process because
that that one little sentence
and that's all it takes is what got me
my first deal i had
alerts up on rightmove for a certain
type of property that i knew i that i
thought would work and made and
from my research i'd done and i just got
this habit of just picking up the phone
yeah hi alex
from seven seas property here um yeah
i'm interested in this property here
how's it there this is the ramp blah
blah blah a few details you get the
pattern right
you get the pattern exactly the process
yeah it's always the process and
get the pattern going and i was like yep
and i'll be interested this would by the
way it wouldn't be me staying there it
would be for corporate let
can i view it at 10 o'clock tomorrow
morning and you know goes one of three
ways
brilliant again and we'll just say this
so what why is that so clever that that
last that last line which is
it's not going to be me living here it
would actually be a corporate that but
i'd love to see it when will be a good
time tuesday or thursday or can you do
tuesday
why is that so good because it just it
shows them it gives them
the impression that what you're doing is
everyday activity yeah it's nothing
untoward it's this is this is what i'm
doing and
i'm ready to view the property i'm ready
to move this isn't something that you
need to be scared of
but naturally estate agents of course
just people yeah and they've got some
questions and then i've got the practice
of going through that conversation
several times and sort of saying right
corporate oh explain to me what does
that mean
well it means i've you know i've got
people in the area who will need
accommodation
where will you be advertising well yes
sometimes it will be on booking.com and
airbnb but
i pitch my properties at the high end of
the market so we always have two night
minimum stay
we furnish them to a very high level and
we take deposits as well and we you know
we do other various checks to make sure
that these people are going to be the
right guests
to who want to stay in a property use it
as
a normal person would and then leave at
the end and then our cleaners go in
and also it's my business model by the
way to look after your property
you know if it's not an a1 condition i
don't have a business um
and so you've got a few knockbacks and
some estate agents like again
that that's some people could be really
thriving so what's this so
oh are there gonna be people in
booking.com but when you learn what to
say
and you have the confidence and you have
people around you that are going you can
do it you can do it
suddenly boom oh my goodness i've got a
deal absolutely i think that that
sentence you taught at the rendering
revolution
combined with sort of the energy from
that room so i was like
right okay it might not happen straight
away but what am i going to do what
goals am i going to set here to make
sure i make this happen
so i in my mind i was like 100
properties i have to view a hundred
properties before i can even begin to
mine about not having a deal
yeah in the end it turned out to be
about four
before you got a deal yeah but that's
that's you set yourself up with the
right expectations because some people
say
right i'm gonna go and do this and then
they get told no and then they get told
no
and then they get told no and then they
quit but for you you're thinking yeah
this is probably going to happen another
97 times yeah and then he's like yes the
fourth time you're pleasantly surprised
go for no exactly so and that's what i
said to myself is if i set myself this
kind of semi-ridiculous goal i know that
somewhere between
20 and 70. you know i'll get a deal
and thankfully you know the deal came
through how long after the rent
revolution did you get that did you book
that viewing so gosh i think it was
must have been maybe like two or three
weeks after
sure i mean i had the deal you had the
offer accepted
well so this is a funny story i saw like
three properties on one morning
i'd actually seen the same property with
two estate agents because the landlord
was desperate to get it let
the tenants who were in situ beforehand
were pretty messy and so every time
people have viewed it they're kind of
gone oh this isn't for me
i was the first person to view a prop
view this first unit we got i was the
first
person to view it after the tenants had
left and the cleaners had been
new build property four or five years
old needed a tiny bit of touching up it
was good to go
i made the offer on a monday i think it
was a tuesday morning i saw on a monday
off on tuesday morning
rang up the state agent on wednesday
like you know because is he up for it an
estate agent already qualified the
property by the way they'd already said
this landlord is up for corporate
potentially other properties just not up
for it i said okay fine
and wednesday morning oh did he does he
like my offer
oh he's oh you know the wife isn't sure
about it you know he's not sure if
you know people won't know how to use
the dishwasher and stuff like this or
the appliances and i'm just like okay so
basically it's a no they're like yes or
no
all right fine okay fine move on let it
go carry on with my week went to another
property training course on the saturday
in london
really small event completely the
opposite end of the scales crash course
there's like 15 people in a room
but still a really great content course
and i have this missed call on a
saturday at five o'clock in the
afternoon from the estate agents
what estate agent called you at five
o'clock on a saturday afternoon and it
was a recording message from this agent
estate agent going alex
offer accepted that white yes
there i was in a room of like 10 or 12
other property people i thought
they just said yes yes i was literally
crying
i really was because i just like i
stacked so much on this i'd quit my job
i
bought money for my family that's funny
i actually had like a business partner
from the
academy before christmas to help me fund
the deal
he essentially gone up to liverpool
instead of buying one deal he got six
deals and he came back to me and said
sorry alex i've got any cash left
so i then met another property another
person through a facebook group actually
who ended up being my investor partner
we went face-to-face first and sort of
qualified each other um but yeah
i've gone through this whole process and
then a deal had come together
and it was funny that it was actually a
genuine objection from the landlord
previously
he was actually a dishwasher engineer by
trade and that's why
he had a genuine objection to it being
used as court of service accommodation
of corporate alerts
so he was there telling showing me all
the ins and outs of the dishwasher and
how
all the filters and him that's the world
right that's everything a lot fair play
fair play but bless him
he was great um you know he's been
really super every time something you're
doing he got it done very quickly
we had a few problems with the boiler
but you know it's all part of the
learning curve and he's
he's footed the bill for that um see i
got that first deal through
i got i picked it up on like 24th of
february i think it was
i spent a couple weeks like getting some
furniture in getting photography and
getting a few
bits finished off in the flat and then
this pandemic thing
was kicking off big time and we weren't
sure you know
there's rooms of lockdown were in the
air and i was like i've got the
photographer
the photographer sent the photos through
got it all nicely done
i'm thinking and i actually laughed to
myself i was like this is this is just
hilarious i just like here we are i've
spent
four or five months stacked my whole
life on this
and now a pandemic's happening although
i couldn't have timed it better could i
i just laughed it i thought i'm not
gonna laugh or cry i choose to laugh
and i thought right what can i do right
now i had it on booking.com i think
i don't think i'd even put it on airbnb
at that point
i was like what can i do i actually
started ringing around local nursing
homes
and i spent the morning ringing up
nursing home saying i've got a
self-isolation
unit you know if you've got anyone who's
extreme risk or something you know
i've got a property here that they could
help them and they weren't interested
but the point is i put the effort in
that morning i said what can i do just
think what any what action can i take
right now to try and get some bookings
in
and that night i quickly put an airbnb
listing together which is really
hilarious because i made a bit of a
[ __ ] on it because when you first do a
listing it says do you want to add an
extra 20
discount your first three guests it's a
brand new property blah blah blah like
yeah yeah fine
so weekly discount monthly discount
actually 20 discount
i ended up giving like you know sort of
basically a 60 discount to this first
guest who made an inquiry but they made
an inquiry for
39 nights almost five you know just over
five weeks worth of bookings
and to have that come in on that morning
i think it's like literally about five
days before lockdown at this point
i was just like you know it wouldn't
give us any profit but at least cover
the bills
and they wanted it for at least five
weeks it's going to cover the rent of
the landlord the bills
at least you can you're going to be at
break even exactly and i've spoken to
the landlord and i'd negotiated a
deferred rent with him so i got a couple
hundred quid knocked off okay for the
next three months as well and that goes
excellent right and and so it all worked
out and and it was great to actually at
that point i'm so glad that it kind of
was cost price because that felt right
at the time for them because everyone
didn't know what's going on
this family actually were living had
grandparents mum and dad and the kids
all in one house so they just wanted to
move the
parents and the kids out because the
they were key workers and working at
sort of sainsbury's
and they didn't want to you know want to
be away from you know they had a
property that they could stay in which
was safe yeah what would you have done
if you hadn't managed to get that
booking would you have had to just tell
the landlord you couldn't pay the rent
because of the pandemic or would you
have had to
or would it just be a disaster it would
it was tough luckily i had a friend of
mine who runs about 50 odd apartments in
the area he does our cleaning
and he was very wise with his marketing
and he approached the key workers and he
had certain people he could
look to so he probably could have got
some key workers in and maybe broken
even maybe not because key workers were
you know generally given a big discount
which is
completely right uh it would have been
tough i'm not quite sure what we would
have done but
when did you get the other two
properties then so they came
in end of july this year because what
happened was
you suddenly got more confidence because
so you would just sort of break it even
but then suddenly it when the lockdown
restrictions lifted
boom you suddenly just off that what did
you make a thousand pound off just that
one property in june
we did so that's incredible it was
awesome so
what did you think when you went when
you had one rent to rent property that
you're really excited about
and then suddenly it's like oh no but at
least you're not losing money to now
one property a grand just in one month i
mean
that no wonder you went and got another
two yeah absolutely
it was pretty incredible the long term
guests we got in before lockdown
they were great they moved out at the
end of may so they wanted to move to a
bit more of a permanent place
and then i just opened up booking.com
again and
i had a couple of contractors stay and
then one person stayed for about three
weeks
a really good nightly rate um and i was
there and i was talking to my business
partner and my investor i was just like
i've done the numbers like three times
but i think we're looking at yeah like
just under a grand profit for this month
and i'm like pinching myself going
right you know through lockdown i was
just like i just kind of let the
property be you know it's paying the
bills i just got into my yoga and my
sort of health and fitness like what can
i focus on right now i'm going to get
really healthy and fit and just
really build on the mental state and uh
and so yeah that happened i thought
right this is a sign i need to
get going with this um and thankfully
just as we were picking up the next two
properties i had an inquiry come in
from an american gentleman who had a
kind of unique situation where he needed
a property to stay in
in maidenhead for about a month or two
or maybe longer whilst him and his wife
looked for a property to buy
in the area and so yes i actually
managed to get him booked in
before i even picked up the keys to one
of the properties so i had a guest in
from like from
technically day number three of picking
up the keys of a property it's a bit of
a whirlwind tour trying to
fit out a property in two days after
picking up the keys but we managed to
again they're smart and i always say
this and this is the kind of thing
people don't do market the property
before you get the keys
so you had you picked up the keys and
you had two days to get it all ready
yeah yeah that sounds like a whirlwind
it was unit number two what do you have
to do to get a property ready what's the
thing so unit number one was was
almost was good to go it had a few
little touch-ups and that's all that was
needed unit two and three
unit two i was in a state of shock when
i saw it because i was like
this was not how i thought it'd be on
the on the pictures i actually put a
holding deposit down
completely naughty naughty note here i
put a holding deposit down without
seeing the property
right because the tenants wouldn't allow
anyone to view it because of the whole
situation they're like we're not having
anyone come into our house
okay fine so no one could view it no one
else was going to make an offer on it
and i knew the location i knew the
buildings had a friend of mine who lived
in the same unit
in the same development and um
so i put this holding deposit down i
said my business partner i know the
place will be fine and i go and view it
for the first time
three hours after the old tenants have
left before it's even been cleaned
and i'm there going oh crumbs there's a
lot of work that i was doing here how
much deposit did you buy
oh so i mean the depo i pay
i only paid like 300 pound holding
deposit i think so
yeah and you know there was a wardrobe
door that was smashed
um there was just like crack tiles
scuffs everywhere not quite holes in the
wall but
bits were hanging off and all sorts and
it was a high-end property really one of
the most extensive properties of
maidenhead for what it is
um and so i knew if i could if i could
turn it around i could make it work
um so so luckily we did we gave a long
list to the estate agents they got it
done through the handyman
um the landlord put a lot of his own
money in to get it all sorted
it still wasn't quite ready because the
landlord put so much money into it it
already eaten up the previous
tenants deposit just to get the place
right again um
and we went in there and it was it still
needed a painting and there's one of
those moments where
you can't plan for everything and we
ended up shelling out more money to get
it painted
but we're still looking really good
because we actually got profit almost
from
monthly turnover profit from day one
because of the you know we're charging
the guests to price which is obviously
more than our cost
as a business should be um so uh
it's gonna be a couple of months until
that breaks even breaks even but
it's it's not looking too bad yeah
because because you put your money in
but even if it
takes you a year to get your money back
that's that's a 100 return on investment
exactly so if you've made all your money
back after two months then they're after
it's just profit
that's not too bad so did you have to
paint it yourself fortunately not no
i was throughout this whole process i've
very very
been very keen to make sure i don't do
the heavy lifting myself i
with the family food business i've done
plenty of heavy lifting in the past i've
been to see the osteopath cardi
chiropractor you name it i was like that
doesn't work my my skill here
is bringing the right people in at the
right time yeah right get the guests in
get the get the skilled people to do
their job because they're skilled at it
i can't do everything yeah and so you're
the entrepreneur
i guess so you don't want to be a
headless chicken doing everything
exactly
so so those go on there was a funny
moment with the painting though so the
guest is there saying alex you know sort
of my wife joining me in two weeks time
he
had literally flown in from america you
said you'd have this property ready but
it's just not ready yet
i'm really sorry stuff's happened it's
not gone as quick as we thought it's
difficult to get hold of parks because
of the whole pandemic and supply issues
what about the paintings i'm going to
bring them up so turns out landlords
already spent so much money he can't pay
for painting as well
i then it's like the painting needs to
be done by friday it's now a tuesday
i get this painter to come around on
like a wednesday morning it's like at 10
o'clock
i'm there at the the unit with the guest
waiting for the painter to come in and
it like the
paint is going to come at 10. it's 10 to
10. i'm chatting with the guest just you
know trying to get to know him a bit
more and just reassure him that we're
going to get the work done
10 to 10 i get what's that voice message
from the painter go alex mate really
sorry i think i've tried to take on too
much this week i don't think i'm going
to be able to do it
i step outside sorry my god give me a
minute i'm just going to said yeah hi
yeah
yeah sorry mate so it's the painter i'm
talking to you i was like yeah
so you need to come round you need to
give me a quote
okay i think you can do this we don't
need the ceilings done we don't need one
of the bedrooms done it's less work than
you think i
really need you to come around so i've
got this guest who's going to be there
potentially for quite a few months
you know who's about to be coming in
like how many days
and his you know his wife's coming in a
few days and she because she's high risk
so the painters need to be finished and
done
uh so the guest is already in at this
point that was a mistake i moved him in
i could have moved him into my other
unit
whilst i got this one ready but he
insisted that he needed the extra space
bless him
which is fair enough but so that was a
bit of a tangle as well whilst he was
getting stuff done once he was already
in there
and it's one of those moments where just
not letting go and having that vision
and saying this properties can be
painted and this decorator was on an
exterior painting job
and it was that was when the
thunderstorms came so because the
thunderstorms came he could justify not
being
doing his outside job for two days to
come do the painting for us just in time
for it all to be finished there's one of
those moments where you just have to
hang on i said you need to come around
and half an hour later he was there
gave the quote did the painting two days
later and it was all done
great but it's that what it's that kind
of thing that builds
character i guess and yeah you know i
mean it's funny because i've got those
kind of problems but on a
much bigger scale you know oh we need to
get you know the roof
taken off um but but no that's really
great so you've got your three
properties now
which are which is paying you basically
a full-time um
i mean it depends on what people define
as a full-time income but to a lot of
people it's a full-time income what's
the next um plan then what are you where
where are you going to go from here
great questions i had lots of bits to
tidy up but
my goal for this year was always to have
10 units um so
so far i've gone for the buy first sell
later so i'm buying getting
putting the money into the units and
then trying to sell the sell the knights
basically yeah
now i'm going to try and flip that model
so i want to be selling first before i'm
buying so become more of a consultant to
corporates coming into the area
and say russian you want property but
you don't want it for a whole year
okay how much you needed for you needed
for six months here's the nightly rate i
can offer you
and then use that use those deposits to
then go and put deposits down
onto properties to make sure that i'm
getting someone in there from day one
yeah the bills are paid for at least the
first three months and therefore i'm no
longer exposing myself that much because
it's a changing economy as we all know
at the moment who knows what the next
six months is going to hold
um we've got a great business model
working now it needs a huge amount of
work doing too i've been very
you know the bookings have come and i've
done very little on the marketing side
and that's the thing is to really
approach the business now as a marketing
exercise where
i need to get get people in i need to
have weeks in advance booked up
so i can cash flow properly build the
systems in place get everything as many
things automated as possible
and so then i can step back from the
business that the moving parts
work and then i can work on expanding it
that's great and
i think one of the reasons that you've
become uh successful now is because of
how focused you've been with it you know
you've been so focused and i think you
need to do that a lot of people are like
i've got um
you're a creative kind of person yeah
and you're a natural entrepreneur so
you've got all these different ideas and
this
but actually to say no this is my
personal goal to do my sailing
this is my business plan which is my
service accommodation rent-to-rent
property business and i'm gonna and i'm
gonna focus on that which is then going
to give me that and it becomes
clear and that's and i guess that's part
of what the academy is it's putting
together
a clear business plan for people
absolutely um
so so that's really exciting talk to me
a little bit about the um
the funding of this because you haven't
done this with your own money have
you no very true so um i i sort of
thought to myself okay i'm going to need
and this is a big step change actually
because my dad had been
supporting the family by himself up
until the recession and he was always
like oh son you know i've been bringing
the money in your mum's been looking
after you guys you know
it's just been me bringing all the money
and i've always been like oh it's got to
be just me then
saving the family as it works i had the
silly idea that i'd save the family
inside
ten years later we've done lots of
things but trying to bring this big pot
of money and just hasn't happened
so i've got to work with people and
that's what i've started to realize that
i've
again sort of i thought i was in a
recession but i would you say i was in a
recession
the uk had moved on the world moved on
and i always thought i had to do
everything by myself and i thought this
is crazy there's almost eight billion
people on the planet
why am i trying so hard to do this by
myself yeah so getting involved with the
academy get around the right people and
get some business you know
people people i trust and i feel
comfortable with
that i can work with yeah and that was
so key and i found uh
i literally i love chatting to people
and you said you love sort of meeting
people instead of being on their journey
not
throughout this period i was meeting up
with people on like almost a daily basis
having coffee with them i just
loved having this conversation about
property and sort of explaining what i'd
learned and sort of if i could help them
at all or maybe they'd be able to help
me etc
i just went on a just went for a drink
with someone i'd met on a face on a
property facebook group
i had no intention of pitching to him at
all i said i had this business partner
but he bought so many properties in
liverpool he doesn't have any cash left
to help me out
um and and i said you know i'm looking
for someone who's got like you know
probably maybe sort of 10 grand
to sort of you know kick this off
because i just want to make sure we've
got enough
for several months worth of rent and all
the furniture
bought up front we can always then lease
it afterwards if we need to
and um and i was just chatting very
casually and he goes yeah sure i've got
that
yeah and i was just like oh and how much
money
did he have to put into that deal so he
i think he put 10 10 000 in but he's now
got all his money back out thanks to the
bounce back loan so we've managed to
make use of that but now he's ready to
put more money in if we need it
for the properties going forward with my
new business model we hopefully won't
have to rely on that so much
but he's got himself into a deal where
he's still full-time work so he's very
much like alex this is
your project i'm happy to help where i
can with the money and he's also great
to bounce ideas off him and that's
something else i've benefited from just
even if it's a phone call once a week he
just has other ideas i don't have of
course
yeah and just you know you know what
it's like when you bring people together
the sum is more than total of the parts
or one of those sayings they say you
know
you're better off working with people
than you are by yourself basically so
you've not put you didn't put your own
money into the into the
into the event around you also didn't
put your own money into the uh
into the training on the account
technically no yeah and some people will
say you know oh
that's really fortunate you've been but
you have to make that happen still
yeah i think to myself i took money from
my parents but i also spent a decade
trying to support my family as well so
it kind of swings swing some roundabouts
um
i think a lot of people get this idea of
like oh you know but you haven't earned
it and if you look at around
in the world sort of there are people
who work every hour in the day
they they should be paid so much but
they're not and there are some people
who work hardly at all and they get paid
huge amounts so earning money is
probably not the way forward it's it's
about
your mindset it's about the people
you're surrounding yourself with and
it's about creating opportunities
i've heard lots of you know examples of
people who have come from nothing to
to something and it's they've had that
as you say that focus
if you have that focus and you just say
i'm going to keep on going i'm going to
outwork the challenges
i'm going to keep on going until the
problems fall away
that's that's been the key well i don't
think you any successful person
has done everything with their own money
that's stupid like
the way to build a large portfolio the
way to become successful
is to use other people's money yeah and
people say oh you got lucky because
other people gave you the money no
no i created a good plan and i pitched
it to people and they invested in it
yes i made myself an investable person
so but i think people will always try
and justify
oh that person is only successful
because of this that and the other
because that person invested in them or
because
just because it makes them feel better
about their own lack of success
and it's funny sort of thinking about it
i was like i was always so keen on
grafting
you know like go to work and stuff this
working hard thing
hasn't served me that well i've had i've
had an awesome life i've got so many
things to be grateful for but
in the working life it didn't really
serve me that well just grafting you
know it didn't really
it's only just about paid the bills i
want more than that i can have more than
that so
it's got to be about working smart and
as you say being an investable person
and my business partner met me i was
very honest with him sort of my
you know i've got debts i've got credit
cards i've got you know i took out
i borrowed money to support my family in
the recession and then i
wasn't very i wasn't very able to pay
that back unfortunately so i've made
huge financial mistakes in the past but
as i mentioned
you know we spent every week for a year
with my family and us all having a
family meeting to get our finances back
on track so that was kind of my
financial baptism of fire i guess say
right i can run a balance sheet i can
you know make sure we're paying our
bills on time so this must mean i can
run a you know i should be able to run a
business as well and yeah
has probably changed because would you
say property has changed your life
oh yeah without a doubt without a doubt
i mean it's it's
having a product like this that you can
feel like you're really serving people
you know when i get the feedback on the
text message and say hey how was it they
go you know they've really enjoyed the
property and it's been really great and
they've had a great time there whether
it's been a family or a contractor et
cetera
um and you know it property changed my
life back in 2005 2006
my dad was investing you know we had a
fantastic lifestyle we're getting on
holidays and everything and dad had a
nice new car etcetera
and so yeah it's just changed i guess
it's changed my life twice actually yeah
and i guess we can't we can't we can
only learn from the past but
if your dad had had a little bit more
property education back in 2005
i mean who knows who knows yeah it's
it's one of those funny things i
i never look back and regret but it's
always interesting to think you know
what could have been
yeah um but for me it was
what i learned through that whole
process was how much i value and it
sounds cheesy again but
my family you know throughout that
period my friends are so supportive my
family are so supportive
um you know extended family as well and
friends and i just thought
i felt so rich even though we had barely
a penny between us
i felt so rich for what i did have and i
just thought you know thank you for that
and i just really appreciate it being in
the moment and i think
if i had made a whole load of money for
me personally earlier on in life maybe i
wouldn't have valued it as much
but now i can see what it's like to go
without almost um
and now i can really value it and i can
really you know spend time being present
and rather than just chasing the money
the money is great the money is
something we need in this
in this in this country to live in and
to to move forward and to have some sort
of
reasonable uh experience of living uh
but it's not everything
um and actually i'm so grateful for my
family friends my girlfriend yeah
did you think when when you were at the
crash course and you were thinking about
the academy
did did did you were there many reasons
what we're trying to tell you
to not do it like was there a lot of
little voices that were saying maybe do
it in six months or maybe there was
certainly sort of a point because i'd
already spent you know
a fair bit of money up until that point
you know sort of ask mom and dad for
some help you know from because they had
a bit of cash to one side and
i was like you know i really want to
make this happen and
i just you know you you don't know what
you don't know of course
but i could just feel in that room i
think over the last 10 or 12 years i've
learned to trust myself i've spent
thousands of pounds on training courses
in the past that i just never used
for sure and but at that point i was
like no i know myself well enough that
i've
i've burned so many bridges for sure i
can fall back on stuff if i need to but
i'm making this happen this is you know
i'm really going to focus on this 100
and this is really what i want to do
i've never felt quite like this
about doing a project before you know
the food business was to support my
family
other businesses in the past were just i
was just having a go this was something
where i could you know
liquid nitrogen ice cream is it's not
something people need although my
girlfriend would disagree
it's uh it's something people want you
know it's a nicety but property it's
something you can touch and feel
i thought if i'm providing a service
like that to someone that's going to
always be in demand and i feel good
providing that service as well yeah
there's that kind of peace of mind and
that satisfaction for me as well
so what was the crash course like that
what was the experience of the two days
it was intense
it was intense and it was it was funny
actually seeing so we broke out to
various groups to do different
activities phony estate agents etc
and some people there you know sort of
like i'll do this but i hate it when
they take my money and i'm just laughs
i was just like well if you're not gonna
invest your money you're gonna invest
your time and i don't think you're gonna
bother investing your time because
you're just kind of sat there going
why are you trying to sell to me it's
like there's obviously a business model
here
you it's unsustainable to just throw
charity at something and it's also
as i've tried to support a few people
over over time as well with their
property journeys or their life journeys
and
um when i've given my time for free you
know it's not valued unfortunately which
is a great shame but
if you charge something you put a value
on it it gets people engaged and it
makes sure that they
they work for it and pull it forward
that's certainly my case i know if i'm
sort of taking borrowing some money from
my parents especially
i really need to make this work you know
i need i need to make sure and i'm the
type of person that if i
you know i don't i always remember every
time someone sent me something and i
always it's on i've got a
big list but i'm getting through it of
you know people that i want to pay back
yeah um and that's very important to me
and what did you think
when you saw all the controversial
headlines and things on social media
it's just like i don't know you
personally
and something that uh what's the chap
said mark
rob moore says you know if you don't
hear it from the horse's mouth
you know who's to say what it really is
and i really like that thought actually
um you know i've i've got a feeling that
you know
i know what you're about you're here to
share and give and i know what that
feels like because i
support i've supported many people over
the years whether it be
emotionally not not usually financially
but sort of
helping them build their mental state
and that's what i actually live for
property is great but if anything that's
above property for me is actually
supporting other people
um sometimes it's been family friends
and other people i've met and when
you're supporting people and helping
them grow there's such
satisfaction in that you've got to put a
price on it because otherwise you can't
expand it and it needs to you know the
funnel needs to keep on moving forward
so it can then
serve more people but in terms of
controversy
i was like i know the energy i felt in
that room i know the content
and the course it's got to be legit
because you've purchased properties
you've built a property portfolio
um and you've got other people who are
in the field every single day like
aleister cunningham and other people who
train
and ryan ryder who's obviously a big
property investor as well
and i was like it doesn't make this
can't this isn't just a whole lot of
rubbish here it doesn't make sense
you know otherwise there'll be no
results at all there's plenty of results
to be spoken for
it's just unfortunately the people that
don't have results that's being
amplified that's
currently louder than the people that do
have results and i think it's often the
case that
people who've got results are too busy
building onto the next results
yeah whereas people who haven't got
results are trying to find excuses to
justify the lack of progress and
it's a really harsh thing to say but
from my experience
any time when i've moaned about someone
there's
so much i could have done that situation
there's so much i could have changed and
just pulled my finger out and just gone
i need to make this happen if i if i
spend my time looking backwards i pull
myself backwards if i spend my time
looking forwards it's tough sometimes
but i can surely make sure i'm getting
closer to the next step forward because
you're in a very similar situation
if you compare you and that guy i can't
remember his name now but the guy who
quit his job
at the dfe like it's interesting how you
both have yeah
he was he wanted to do property and you
know i was i want to do property and
i think i just maybe because i put more
weight on it i i don't know
i don't know him particularly well we
kept in contact a bit but he
quit his job and he then totally spun
around on what
he said he was committed to making
property happen and i said to myself i
was committed to making property happen
and it's so funny you get all these kind
of shiny pennies all over the place like
oh this deal over here this opportunity
over there
but it's about it's my sister says slow
and steady wins the race
it really is true just i had this goal
of service accommodation
in early part of 2020 i was rushing down
to portsmouth looking at deals for beat
by refurbish
and i was talking to a friend of mine
who'd take the drag me you know and drag
me along bless me alex can come and help
me i said yeah sure let's have a look at
it i love
you know going to see places and i love
being by the seaside um
and like we sort of did two or three
viewings over two or three days
and i said to him i said mate his name
is seb actually i think he's on the
academy and i said
what's your if i said to you what's your
number one goal in 2020 what is it he
goes i'll expand my amazon business
i'm like exactly that's why we're
struggling to get a deal here
my focus is not a buy refurbish
refinance deal it's serviced
accommodation
and as much as i'm happy to look at a
deal i always have to look but i know
where my focus lies because i've been
unfocused in the past i know the danger
being unfocused because you just kind of
put a bit of energy everywhere and
nothing really goes forward
and i think sort of his amazon business
is now doing really well
i'm very grateful that my service
combination business is now doing really
well
and it shows that that focus is is so
key um
and if you if you're really focused on
something you're focused on it and
there's
you really should be unmovable on that
yeah to the point where you literally
have people pulling you back
sometimes physically to stop you going
in that direction
and if you've got a true vision it's
about saying that over and over again
and i think since january this year i've
been firming every morning my goals and
what i want to achieve
and despite this horrendous pandemic
that the whole world has been
experiencing over the last six months
i'm actually thankfully still making
progress towards that yeah
and do you think sometimes if it's not
working or you're not getting the
results you want after maybe three or
even six months
it might be because you need to keep
going and give it maybe nine or twelve
months
and people sometimes get frustrated
because the thing is if you if you go to
university
three months into university if you're
if you're if you go to drama school
after three months you don't get all
annoyed because you're not a hollywood
star
yes you say well i'm not a minute i need
to i need to do my training and i need
to implement my training and then i'm
gonna
start seeing results and people
sometimes maybe maybe they come to the
property investors crash course they pay
a pound
and then they walk out and then within
uh two weeks
they're frustrated that they're not
financially free but it's like come on
it's a process and you need to follow
the process it's the same as
getting slim and you can do it and it's
completely possible
and it's simple and you could say it's
easy but you've got to actually
follow the process and you've got to do
it over a period of time consistently
what do you think
so true i mean one of the statements i
took from the crash course was
environment is stronger than willpower
yeah and you know
that's why i knew joining academy i'll
be around people who are all heading in
the same direction
and and it is a process and i think i
feel so grateful for the experiences
i've had so far in life where
i've tried many different business
projects some have gone well some not so
well
and i could see that you know what was
really limiting was just my vision at
the time and actually being held
accountable that's another big thing
that you talked about the crash course
is making sure that
if you say you're going to do something
you damn well do it
and i think when you when you're held
accountable like that to take these
actions
you've got to understand that there's a
pain process to go through when i'm
looking at my goals i sometimes feel
sick
genuinely so i can feel my stomach
turning and i can feel that
the alex i am today has got to literally
be ditched and there's going to be a new
alex tomorrow and it's all these cheesy
things
they sound cheesy but it's what makes
sense in my mind is that
if i'm going to achieve more tomorrow i
have to let go of the person i was today
and it's being an environment which
constantly pushes you forward and it is
uncomfortable and
if it's if it's not uncomfortable you're
probably not pushing yourself yeah it's
something you actually talked about in
the academy as well is your reason why
if you know your reason why there's no
problem getting out of bed
there's no problem with sticking up for
some you know
for a deal you need to make or an
activity you need to do to take the next
step forward
and that y is what's going to get you up
in the morning lots of people say yeah i
want the 10 grand a month
but unless they can pinpoint exactly
what every one of those pounds are going
to be used for
there's no reason behind it it's just a
sum it's a nice figure i was doing some
planning with my girlfriend the other
day
and i sort of had this figure of what i
want to be earning in a few months time
and she's like wow that's a lot of money
i was like yes
but it's for the rent the more
the more so the rent utility bills the
car insurance the life insurance all of
these things and then this is going to
be this much for our food bill
and i could pinpoint every single pound
and how it was going to be spent
and also a whole income expenditure
method um you know to make sure we've
got savings we've got education we've
got a bit to give to charity a bit to
spend on holiday etcetera and when you
give meaning to all of those pounds you
think
people go gosh that's a lot of work i
was just like yeah it is because you're
going from a place where you're not
thinking about these questions to a
place where you are and that's going to
be uncomfortable like i said
i feel sometimes a bit sick inside when
i set these goals because i know i'm
pushing myself forward
but if you can if you can go through
that and you can be
bold enough to let go of yourself from
the past and say i need to create
something new in the future
yeah then you've got an opportunity to
move forward yeah and i think what you
said about environment is so important
being around
like-minded people yeah what would you
say to somebody that was considering
going down to a crash course or
enrolling on some training but
i think in two minds do i really need to
do this what would you what would your
advice be
first of all i'd say if you
100 if you've got someone that's close
to you that's on the same wavelength as
you
then by all means take them with you but
actually you might be better off just
going by yourself
and when you're in that room you're in a
room of maybe a couple hundred people
you probably don't know anyone in there
just find out who you feel attracted to
just find out you know what feels good
if you hear someone having
an exciting conversation is that
something you want to listen to you've
got someone else in the corner saying oh
i don't know why i came to this
probably leave them you've got an
opportunity there to create new
connections
you know get involved make the most of
the day because they're an amazing the
people in that room are the
sort of one or one end or the other of
the spectrum or somewhere in between
either they've got money
and they want to know how to invest it
or they don't have money and they want
to learn how to become investable
so then they can invest other people's
money in the future um
and wherever you are on that spectrum
you're going to be able to find someone
else who's at the opposite end
who needs some of your skills yeah and
people have been surprised at me when
they go
yeah but what do you mean i'm just like
well how do you do this whole property
thing and i went
i committed myself to have the time to
go into property full-time
i've been learning about it and studying
it sort of on a daily basis the last
eight nine months and being
on the courses i'm someone who's in my
time and interest is invested
in in knowing my skill knowing this
property i'm still a beginner for sure
i've got lots to learn but i know more
than an investor who's spent their
working life on a nine-to-five job
putting money in a savings account who
hasn't got the first idea about how to
invest it
otherwise it wouldn't be in the savings
account and i've actually had people
because i got up on stage and i sort of
put myself out there i had people come
up to me and sort of say
alex you know um i've got some funds
i don't have the time to invest it can
we please have a chat yeah
and that's happened to me on several
occasions actually um and
i'm sort of you know i really enjoy the
environment and i love sort of meeting
people and greeting people
when i'm there but when you go to those
when you go to the crash course
just you've got an opportunity to make
new connections and just think right
what do i want to get out of this you
know what positivity can i take from
this
yeah and really set yourself a goal
after that crash course and say
well i've been i spent this one or two
days studying and learning about
property
what is my goal you know in the next
year is it to get one deal in the next
six months is it to try and get two rent
to service accommodation properties is
it just to set up your limited company
it doesn't matter what that goal is
as long as you set it and as long as you
find someone who's on the same
sort of wavelength as you to help keep
you accountable that's the key thing
i think that's really important because
a lot of people think going to a crash
course or
joining samuel 365 doing something in
the academy even
i think it's just about the learning and
the learning is obviously
a major major part but there's also the
the people that you're going to meet
and we deliberately set it up in such a
way whereby we hook people up we connect
people we make it
make that happen so it's been really
good chatting and i'm i'm really
um proud of what you've achieved and
thank you looking forward to seeing you
continue
uh to build your business from strength
to strength guys i hope you enjoyed that
interview and found it really useful
please do drop
a nice comment below for alex also smash
the like button
if you'd like to see more winners
wednesday interviews like this
every single week i interview somebody
on this youtube channel
who's become financially free or have
their life and their finances
revolutionized through
training and through property if you
want to see more interviews like that
you can watch them right here
also please don't forget to subscribe
down here and you might enjoy watching
this video too
up here click more subscribe and i'll
see you
next time